- Hallo? Wir wurden gerufen!
- Hallo! Ähm, ja! Das Ganze ist uns
wirklich unglaublich peinlich,
aber es handelt sich um ein
ärgerliches Missverständnis.
- Ein Missverständnis?
- Ja. Wir können das aber alles,
äh, erklären!
- Hm.
- Max?
- Ja.
Ähm, es war normaler
Betrieb zur Mittagszeit.
Nico saß im hinteren Bereich.
- Ja und dann begann Inge zu husten.
- Alles in Ordnung, Inge?
- Es klang richtig gefährlich.
Sie wurde ganz rot.
- Hier … trink das! Trink das!
- Inge trank das Wasser und
der Husten wurde etwas besser.
- Inge lächelte sofort wieder,
ging aber auf Toilette,
um sich frisch zu machen.
- Ich geh' mich schnell frisch machen.
- Wir sind dann zurück
in die Küche gegangen,
während Nico offenbar mitbekam,
dass Inge auf der Toilette
wieder einen Hustenanfall bekam.
- Davon hatten wir gar nichts mitbekommen,
weil die Tiegelwurst angebrannt ist.
- … und als ich das
in der Küche gesehen habe,
rief ich laut: Scheiße, die tote Oma!